d'accord on passe au coeur au coeur du
podcast avec toi donc jo coach en
développement personnel à l'asvel je le
rappelle donc tu travailles avec deux
joueurs qu'on suit de près on va surtout
parler théo malade on évoquera aussi
matthew strazeele théo mal et donc donc
d'après les analyses parlait des beach
boys démographe tu qui sont publiés ici
et là à l'unanimité il sera drafté
probablement au premier tour en juin
prochain pour on n'est jamais sûr de
rien évidemment
c'est dan il joue le championnat et
l'euroligue seulement 19 ans romain je
te laisse la première question à jo bats
tout simplement ou est ce qu'il en est
pour toi aujourd'hui par rapport aux au
développement développement sur les
choses qui avaient éventuellement à
perfectionner les cuit par rapport à
l'échelle de temps que vous étiez
éventuellement fixés en termes de
objectif de progression va faire très
large
alors on a pris du retard de par sa
blessure à l'épaule en début de saison
maintenant actuellement aujourd'hui là
il est sonné sur le rhône est sur la
bonne voie on a pris du retard mais vaut
mieux mal commencé où commencer soe de
et de bien finir donc là on continue à
bosser et là il est sur une bonne
période et il est en confiance et la
honte
on est bien en ce moment là on est on
est bien on a récupéré le temps perdu on
va dire d'accord est ce que le fait
d'avoir aussi un calendrier aussi lourd
ça pèse au niveau du travail que toi tu
veux effectuer avec lui
quel est le bon dosage entre avoir du
temps de jeu et prendre du temps pour le
développement personnel
alors c'est là où c'est c'est important
il faut soit analysée parce qu'on joue
énormément donc on a beaucoup moins de
temps donc
et lui c'est un joueur qui a besoin de
se ils se regroupent sur sur l'autre sur
le travail c'est à dire en musculation
ou sur le travail technique
en fait il se cache derrière ça et il a
raison c'est un gros travailleur donc il
a besoin de ça et c'est vrai qu'on
- le temps de travail et donc il faut
cibler en fait il faut faire des
sessions plus courte mais toujours
rester toujours à avoir cette activité
est toujours s'améliorer donc mais après
et eos et j'ai eu la chance et j'ai la
chance d'entraîner pas mal de joueurs et
théo c'est le plus gros travailleur il
s'avère qu'après les matches on est
capable d'être à 8 heures du matin à la
salle parce qu'on il est pas content de
son match donc donc
donc pour en revenir à ta question par
rapport au temps de travail on a moins
de temps de travail mais on essaye de de
maximiser en fait le peu de temps qu'on
a deux
voilà justement maximiser le temps que
vous avez pour travailler quoi qu'est-ce
qui est qu'est-ce qui est le plus
important
romain te demandais tout à l'heure où ou
des eaux en été au niveau du
développement
qu'est-ce qui est la priorité en ce
moment et dans les mois à venir avant la
draft la priorité en ce moment il est
bien il fait des matches intéressants du
manque et de l'adresse
donc on faisait bon fait mon moins de
shoots on a fait moins de deux sessions
de deux shoots ces temps c'est parce que
de par le calendrier aussi on faisait
beaucoup moins que l'année dernière par
exemple là donc on réduit le temps mais
on en fait quand même donc là par
exemple pour moi et du manque de
l'adresse en ce moment là à ce moment là
après sépare c'est par période en fait
c'est une analyse il ya des moments où
il fallait travailler ses pick and roll
la capacité à changer de rythme où il a
progressé sa défense aussi parce que le
travail individuel c'est pas que que la
taxe et sa défense on s'est appuyé à
donc en fait c'est par c'est par
l'analyse qu'on fait d'eux de ses
besoins en fait sur le moment sûrement
augmenter donc donc c'est ça pour toi il
lui manque justement tu pars lui parlé
de beaucoup de choses que vous avez
travaillé après tu le sais très bien il
ya pour aller en nba pour être drafté il
ya un argumentaire de vente entre
guillemets c'est j'aime pas parler comme
ça mais ça ça reste quand même les des
personnes qu'on va sélectionner sur
justement 1 1 ou de ce qu'ils vendent
heures entre guillemets nous de capacité
à faire des choses de manières enfin
mieux que les autres
quoi qu elle qu'est ce que j'imagine que
vous avez déjà identifié là-dessus quels
sont les points forts peut-être à
accentuer quels sont les points faibles
à masquer à gommer alors je vais
commencer par les points faibles le
coach était et dur sur lui exigeant sur
lui sur ce point là c'est c'est sa
défense il a vraiment progressé sur sa
défense et là il peut aussi encore
passer un cap
notamment par rapport à l'heure de
passer les écrans il est mieux sur sur
la défense sur la défense individuelle
sur l'homme sur l'homme
c'est sa capacité à défendre va être clé
en s'il veut aller de l'autre côté
pourquoi parce que les arrières sont
beaucoup plus rapides et le terrain est
beaucoup plus grand donc là ça va être
sa capacité à défendre à défendre à être
régulier sur cet aspect là de l'autre
côté après en attaque
je pense que vous connaissez théo c'est
un joueur talentueux altruiste grands
avec de bonnes mains qui a une bonne
vision de jeu
aujourd'hui qui arrive vraiment à jouer
avec une autre un peu intensité il s'est
hissé un peu allante ici l'intensité de
l'euroligue
il faut savoir que la situation à
l'asvel elle est pas facile pourquoi
parce qu'on joue avec vraiment du joueur
au jour une compétition comme
l'euroligue où il est arrivé que théo
joue des matches cinq minutes ou donc
c'est pas vraiment facile de s'exprimer
mais on continue à travailler continuer
à travailler tous les jours et le
travail finit par payer le coût
je le disait clairement la dernière fois
en or si on jouait en eurocoupe il
laisserait hétéro jouer 25 30 minutes en
match et héros forêt une saison à a bien
meilleures saisons maintenant là c'est
un autre niveau plus exigeants on a une
grosse équipe et c'est pas évident donc
c'est pour ça que quand on me demande
sorteo il faut tout remettre dans son
comté moi je j'ai de l'an dernier
j'avais faim sur la saison dernière je
les ai vus jouer si cette fois et sur le
début de cette année un petit peu
si j'avais eu une faiblesse réelle à
retenir entre guillemets c'était le fait
qu il se passe énormément impacter sur
les écrans que je sois tu m'en a parlé
je sois sur les pick and roll
directement ou les et chrome en porter
il se faisait beaucoup beaucoup touché
est-ce que sk - autres c'est scellier a
à a de la vitesse d'appui est-ce que
c'était lié sait où s'était lié à
peut-être une prise d'un faux ou
peut-être une anticipation qui était pas
suffisante et questions complémentaires
est ce que les petits pets qu'il a eu à
l'épaule on peut aussi renforcer un peu
l'appréhension que tu peux avoir le
joueur par rapport notamment à la prise
de d'infos sur le choc peut créer
l'écran ça fait peut-être beaucoup d'un
coup comme question mais il ya de quoi
discuter non sur sur son épaule il a
vraiment il a plus d'appréhension
non il a vraiment plus d'appréhension
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il est même
encore plus plus dur parce qu'il se
renforce tous les jours avec manu
lacroix avec le préparateur physique
donc on avait cessé ces questions là au
tout début on disait bon est-ce que ça
va ça va pas l'affecter à ce niveau là
puisqu'il avait déjà des problèmes en
défense mais pas du tout avec le travail
qu'il a effectué en salle de musculation
le renforcement qui continue à faire il
n'a pas du tout d'appréhension
maintenant il s'est hissé au niveau de
l'intensité du coach c'est à dire
l'intensité que le coach demande une
pression tout terrain en porsche
maintenant lui partait avec des lacunes
c'est à dire défensif donc il a il a des
problèmes c'est vrai à l'heure de passer
les écrans par exemple sur sur l'homme
maintenant moi c'est une question de
d'appui est une question de centre de
gravité c'est à dire qu'il faut qu'ils
baissent on travaille encore que ce soit
en attaque ou en défense son centre de
gravité une fois que tu baisses ton
semble de grave
thé situé explosif et tué des appuis
sont sont vite tu vas pouvoir passer
souvent en fait il se relève et donc il
prend et retard du retard et c'est mon
analyse est donc dans quelle mesure est
ce que tu penses que justement ce
travail sur le sort de leurs invités il
est possible parce qu'on sait qu'en
fonction du profil physique de la
hauteur de hanche et est également de ce
que tu peux avoir aussi sur le plan
musculaire on peut plus ou moins plus ou
moins joué sur ce truc là est ce que tu
penses que c'est vraiment un truc qui
est qui et qui est possible à résoudre à
court terme chez lui je pense oui parce
que quand je lui demande quand je lui
demande de le faire ce soit en attaque
ou en défense il est capable de le faire
maintenant c'est passé voilà quand il le
fait il sent tout de suite la différence
maintenant il faut fixer et j'espère que
ça va pas prendre énormément de temps il
faut qu'on y arrive à vendre avant la
fin de l'année maintenant la ilaha illa
déjà pas mal progressé et on continue
c'est un processus un processus et tutus
sait mieux que moi c'est vraiment
difficile de changer les habitudes donc
donc on y est on y est on travaille
dessus collaboration aussi avec le
préparateur physique parce que c'est un
tout quoi les appuis le non-travail
aussi hong kong va en collaboration avec
avec manu pour pour l'aider à à à
progresser dans le cas d'un joueur comme
théo le volume que ça peut représenter
alors en sachant que le calendrier doit
être un peu un peu délirant certaines
semaines mais qu'elle quel volume
horaire ça représente à peu près par
semaine de travail spécifique pour toi
avec le joueur
en comptant enfin sans compter le
travail de prépa physique spécifique par
rapport à lui
non moi je parle de toi si tu veux en
tant que deux ans quand que en tant que
coach je perds développement combien de
temps est-ce que tu penses passé à peu
près avec théo chaque semaine en terme
de temps ouais on entend de temps de
temps de travail
ça dépend vraiment tu sais on joue
vraiment tous les deux jours et c'est
pour ça qu'on est là donc on dépend
aujourd'hui on est mardi on a joué
dimanche à siauliai
donc on est revenu nous on est revenue
que lundi donc ce matin en fait j'ai
travaillé avec lui sa main ce midi là on
a travaillé ensemble à travailler une
heure plus ce soir-là du travail et bien
une heure et demie aujourd'hui
donc là on rejoue après demain donc
demain on va faire trois heures ça va
faire trois heures vendredi après on
joue quand tu vois on joue tout le temps
donc il faut vraiment se je vais prendre
le calendrier pour te dire une semaine
type si tu veux une semaine ce village
pour avoir une idée en plus tous à des
entraînements évidemment coller au jdd
match c'est donc demain après tout ça le
guérisse ouais ouais à l'est un peu
moins ça va faire wen ont un peu moins
comme trois heures à l'aller 25 heures
par semaine cinq heures par semaine ok
un peu près et effectivement avec des
jusqu'au bout pour finir sur ce truc là
et toi toi avec ton canton expérience
perso si vous n'aviez pas l'euroligue où
si une compétition dès qu'un dribble
atteint plus facile à gérer
tu penses qu'idéalement le volume
horaire de travail sur le travail de l
hebdomadaire pour un joueur de ce profil
là ça pourrait de combien pour que ça
reste optimale sans tomber dans du
surentraînement
non justement on en parle en plus en ce
moment tu sais on essaie vraiment
d'optimiser le travail par exemple on
fait du shoot mais en ce moment je
trouve qu'il manque dallerès donc on va
faire du shoot et je veux pas qu'on
passe énormément de temps à la salle
pour pour le traverser
voilà pour l'effet inverse pour le
fatiguer donc par exemple on veut être
sûr allez on est à aller en 30min les 20
minutes
non là aujourd'hui même en 15 minutes il
doit me faire par exemple sur de
l'adresse purin 5 séries sur dix sur dix
aujourd'hui la fête en 30 minutes
c'est sur cette cette série à a
c'était 10 ou 15 10 10 de suite tu vois
donc on essaye de vraiment de taille
mais est de rester un peu sur sur delà
de la qualité que ce soit de la quantité
tu vois ça c'était après l'entraînement
avant l'entraînement on travaille à des
choses un peu plus spécifique
donc on pose moi ta question alors par
rapport à bouffer c'est énoncer tétouan
sur une semaine type ce que ce que tu ce
que tu penses est entre guillemets dans
quai sable si tu veux pour un joueur de
ce profil là pour que ça reste optimale
voilà c'était ici s'il n'y avait pas
l'euro l'i way pour ça reste un petit
malthus et sans tomber sur le
surentraînement ou sans tomber dans une
espèce de routine qui fait que tu sais
comment sais tu t'entraînes tu es dans
l'hyper travail mais il ya un moment où
finalement c'est ce qu'on disait ça
l'effet inverse c'est à dire que tu
bosses - temps voit les effets et au
final tu te mets à l'envers tu vois ça
j'ai ça c'est un peu mon analyse par
rapport au match par rapport à l'état de
fatigue par rapport à au moment où t'as
pas envie de surcharger il ya eu un peu
si on sait rien une altercation avec
avec le coach ou testing c'est une
analyse globale il faut vraiment qu'elle
si on continue toujours à travailler
mais ça se trouve ça va être un peu
moins de temps aujourd'hui on va on va
on va regarder on va faire plus tôt de
la vidéo on va faire de la vidéo juste
après on va travailler sur ce qu'on a vu
à la vidéo tu vois et ça c'est mon
analyse c'est l'analyse que je fais à là
à l'instant un peu instant t et bien sûr
après il ya toujours une base de le
travail régulières mais après on peut
voilà onze jours on joue dessus pour pas
pour pas surcharger
physiquement aussi mentalement le joueur
les joueurs se sont battus avec théo
quoi on a parlé du mental en début de
cette émission c'est quelque chose qu'on
connaît évidemment moins bien que ses
qualités évidentes dans le jeu du côté
de théo comment toi tu juges
on va dire son profil psychologique est
ce que c'est quelqu'un qui parle
beaucoup ce que c'est que quelqu'un qui
intériorise qu intellectualise comment
tu le jugerait sans rentrer dans les
détails au riz psychologique pousser
alors il a thériault reese vachement
c'est pas c'est pas un gamin qui s'ouvre
naturellement à tout le monde qui va pas
parler naturellement facilement à à tout
le monde il intériorise mentalement
savoir que c'est un jeune joueur mais il
se il se construit moi je trouve fort
mentalement parce que je vais pas vous
mentir que notre coach il n'est pas
cessé c'est un bon coach très bon coach
mais les patentes connaissez les côtes
de l'est et il n'est pas il n'est pas
tendre et il y en a fait baver
ils eurent fait pas vu leur faible et
aux autres joueurs donc si mentalement
il est pas fort il ne ferait pas ce
qu'il fait aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup
c'est un aspect pour moi qui est
important on parlait de kobe bryant
voilà ce qu'il s est vraiment
mentalement
rien ne peut te casser continue à
travailler réfléchis et tu dis moi je la
compagne mais je ne sais pas tout on
parle de basket on parle de on parle de
des choses de la vie ccc ccc une
relation un peu particulière mais
mentalement son son environnement
familial est ce que est ce qu'il ya une
forte pression pour réussir est ce qu'il
ya un accompagnement buecher en douceur
un lâcher prise comment tu vois ça toi
depuis ton poste de coach son son
environnement et sain et la c1 c'est un
gamin très très famille sa famille est
ici avec lui ils ont bougé à il est de
rouen ils sont venus à ils sont venus à
lyon ils sont installés il est avec sa
famille ses frères l'ac thann il a
commencé un peu à prendre son
indépendance mais il est très familier
c'est et c'est très bien comme ça parce
qu'aujourd'hui ça peut aller très très
vite avec les réseaux sociaux mais lui
il ya il a vraiment cette stabilité avec
avec sa famille et je trouve c'est ce
qui fait un peu des fois la différence
sur d'autres gamins qui à son âge
peuvent être mais exubérant on va dire à
lui pas du tout là il a ce cocon
familial
ce qui est ce qui est très bien mais pas
de pression particulière l'emploi de
pression particulière cette année pour
être honnête j'ai senti un peu plus de
pression mais de l'extérieur parce que
c'est pas facile à gérer pour la main
quand tu es à l'entraînement ou au début
du match une tare attachez pas comme un
scout qui sont là est leur téléphone qui
quittent film qui doit cesser mais lui
je trouve qu'il qui le gère bien
maintenant il ya la pression est passé
il ya eu au moment où il a il a douté
beaucoup avec sa blessure est revenue je
vois pas beaucoup
il a douté beaucoup je continue à lui
dire qu'il faut continuer à travailler
que ça va venir que c'est une question
de temps que sait on revient pas comme
ça du jour au lendemain d'une blessure
reprendre le rythme regagner la
confiance du coach
donc là il est reparti sur le mode un
peu comme l'année dernière il faut qu'il
retrouve un peu son rythme de croisière
mais pour revenir à ta question famille
allemand s'est pas stable pour finir sur
l'aspect psychologique et ce sera
l'occasion d'évoquer matthew strazeele
dont on aura l'occasion de reparler dans
d'autres podcast on a l'impression d'une
vraie différence et je pense que pourra
le confirmer entre les deux en train
strazeele qui et qui a une mentalité
très américaine très je n'ai peur de
rien et c'est un mal et dont peut-être
plus tu disais moins mois a moins parlé
est-ce que comment comment se dit la
concurrence entre les deux puisque il ya
une concurrence il joue au même poste
ils sont tous les deux jeunes sont tous
les deux ils aspirent tous les deux à
une carrière internationale mois pour
moi il n'y a pas vraiment de différence
et pas même type de joueur non plus
c'est pas je ne sais pas si tu connais
un peu matthew tu vois c'est pas du même
profil c'est pas la même la non non
c'est pas les mêmes points ferait pour
moi il n'y a pas de
c'est une concurrence saine entre 2
matthew est bon en ce moment il a été
bon à cholet l'a été bon au pana il joue
ya pas de problème le coach aime
beaucoup ne peut pas comparer pour moi
je ne peux pas comparer
les deux joueurs tu veux pas comparer
non non je te demande pas le comparer
mais de savoir comment comment il le vit
théo va pas que avec matthew par exemple
aujourd'hui mathieu joue plus qu'antoine
diot pourtant antoine diot c'est antoine
hey oh ouais voyez donc c'est pas c'est
même pas une question de théo matthew
mais ces mêmes edwin joue un peu moins
donc c'est vraiment c'est pour ça que je
vous disais que le coaching de le
management du coach n'est pas un n'est
pas évident et tu dois rester prêt à
tout moment donc là en ce moment en
matthew est prêt il s'entraîne bien et
jouent aux théories pas et bien mais
est-ce que ça peut changer
c'est pour ça que ont ce qu'on se rend
ce 11e on se cache derrière le travail
ont continué à travailler pour reste
quand même resté près jamais être trop
jamais être trop bas toujours avoir
cette régularité et mais lui il est fort
mentalement pour wii surpasser cette
concurrence de façon la concurrence y en
aura toujours qui soit en un lieu qui
soit en euroligue qui soit la
concurrence a toujours donc c'est
comment lui gère cette saine concurrence
il allait il a un coach pour le côté psy
je ne pense pas non je ne pense pas je
n'y suis pas je ne pense pas ok remonte
à une dernière question pour jo non mais
je pense que le nom son jeu on a fait on
a fait le tour du du truc je peux déjà
je te remercie d'avoir d'avoir présenté
un petit peu tout ça parce que c'est
toujours très intéressant à savoir si tu
veux d'entraîneur entraîneur pour voir
un petit peu où vont les uns les autres
de leur façon de bosser et puis
également bas pour pour des jeunes
coaches qui pourrait qui pourra écouter
tous appuyé cherché à s'informer je
trouve qu'il ya peu il ya peu de ya peu
de manière d'échanger réellement entre
nous de manière ouverte comme ça et
public donc c'est merci pour le temps
que tu nous accorde pas en parler cette
façade de ton boulot parce que c'est
super important
tu as dit un mot pour moi qui est très
très juste et qui est un petit peu la
clé tout s'il comptait la détermination
je vais autre chose mais la régularité
et tu l'as mis en avant dans ta dante
attentats dans ta conclusion et je
trouve que c'est c'est quelque chose à
laquelle il faut aspirer quand on est un
jeune joueur il faut il faut être
capable de six chiens
vos minimum d'exigences en dessous
duquel on ne veut plus des cendres et
puis surtout ne pas chercher forcément à
faire des choses extraordinaires tout le
temps où tout de suite il faut petit à
petit trouver la régularité la
régularité on la trouvera en maîtrisant
c'est ce que je dis souvent ce qu'on
sait faire un joueur de haut niveau il
fait ce qu'il sait faire et pas autre
chose et c'est sur ce fond comme ça
qu'on arrive à déceler aussi les mes
jeunes joueurs à potentiel c'est des
gens qui maîtrisent un petit peu plus
cet aspect là et qui sont capables de
deux passes prêtres de ne pas se perdre
pardon route
ouais je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
toi c'est marrant parce que j'en parlais
hier avec anthony brossard le coach des
espoirs ce que je travaille aussi à
l'académie avec les avec les jeunes lors
de voir la vidéo mais voilà il ya c'est
beaucoup mais il ya d'autres joueurs
aussi à l'asvel avec notamment le centre
de formation on investit sur des
serveurs sur des jeunes et aujourd'hui
j'ai l'impression qu'on en parlait hier
que les jeunes ne connaissent pas leur
rôle
donc ils veulent un peu tout faire et
vaut mieux bien sûr trouver cette
régularité mais l'arrêt qui la
régularité aussi elle se trouve dans le
rôle que tu as donc tu es un défenseur
un shooter tu vas rester tu vas tu tues
tu vas tu veux être vocal tu vas tu vas
être le leader
défensivement la tacc on te demande pas
si tu es joueur tu shootes si tu as
vraiment à des haies et ça c'est très
important connaître vraiment son rôle
merci beaucoup de jo dalla service venu
parler tout ça avec nous merci problème
si vous avez encore choses et coutras
guîtres avec plaisir le noir y'a pas de
soucis peut-être se refaire un point
dans quelques semaines dans quelques
mois on pourrait on peut envisager sa
merci pour ton temps merci pour ta
disponibilité
absolument merci à la prochaine car
c'est bien à quoi
[Musique]